thousands came to say their goodbyes
many are feeling they knew Shireen
personally that's how much she connected
with her audience
telling the story of her people
and now becoming the story
[Applause]
her recording but also the love that the
people around the world have for us in
Palestine people know that what Israel
is doing is a war crime and they feel
helpless but today we don't
the occupation she long reported on
[Applause]
started its final Journey to the church
mourners were pushed and beaten by
Israeli forces as they stormed the
hospital Square the Paul Bearer is
retreating her coffin nearly falling to
the ground
[Applause]
Border Police in riot gear on horseback
thank you
baffling scenes at least one man pulled
out of the hearse
Israeli forces also removing the
Palestinian flag
I knew they were not going to let this
day go by peacefully I was on the front
lines when we were trying to exit the
hospital while they were carrying her
casket
and the truth
they were they just stormed in and they
were beating up everyone it was very
frightening to be honest
it was also tension when shireen's body
arrived outside the church in the
Christian quarter of the old city
crowds filling the small streets of this
ancient city
[Music]
but once the coffin made it inside
granted more peace
brought the message of every Palestinian
suffering God created life not to be
assassinated but to be nurtured
was shot dead in the occupied West Bank
while on an assignment in the Janine
refugee camp
her funeral procession was joined by
thousands of Palestinians the show of
the widespread affection and admiration
she had earned through her years of
reporting on their lives
SRI nabawaka was buried next to her
parents at the Mount Zion Cemetery
both her parents died in the early
stages of her career and never knew how
loved and respected she'd become
the crowds have gone the family has gone
shireen's grave has now been sealed but
even after her death she continued to
tell the Palestinian story Stephanie
Decker Al Jazeera in occupied East
Jerusalem